vous avez aujourd'hui écoutez je suis
déjà contente d'être au deuxième tour
parce que ça n'allait pas de soi certes
je suis sortante mais je dois aussi
porter je le comprends bien un bilan
extrêmement mauvais et donc gelé
contesté mais je comprends bien que pour
les citoyens ça ne suffisent pas et
qu'on y compris on est beaucoup qui a
l'impression que ça n'a pas de sens
d'aller voter mais je leur rappelle
quand même que l'alien il ya un enjeu il
ya un enjeu démocratique majeur
les candidats dans marchand signer une
charte moi j'entends que les gens
veuillent donner une majorité au
président mais c'est bon ils là et il ya
quand même un enjeu ils ont signé une
charte disant qu'ils allaient voter ce
que le président propose et enfin je
pense c'est vraiment un problème les
parlementaires les députés c'est les
représentants du peuple des citoyens
c'est pas les parts paroles ou les
attachés de presse du président de la
république ou du gouvernement
donc la majorité il là mais il ya
vraiment un enjeu on est dans une
situation incroyable où le ministre de
la justice fait pression sur france
inter où la ministre du travail porte
plainte contre la presse qui divulgue le
projet de loi du travail et je dis aux
citoyens il ya un enjeu concret immédiat
sur cette discussion sur la loi du
travail qui va permettre que des accords
d'entreprise d'ailleurs presque passé
entre les salariés et les patrons
passent au delà des accords de branche
les accords de branche et ce qui permet
que un accord négocié un niveau de la
branche s'applique à tous les salariés y
compris ceux qui t'ont dans des
entreprises dans lesquelles n'y a pas de
représentation syndicale il se prépare
des choses vraiment grave donc on a
besoin de parlementaires qui
représentent les barbes